google qui est à la barre des témoins
mais si stephen harper dont on fait le
procès j'ai demandé à monsieur d'affi de
rembourser 6 devant et quand j'ai appris
le contraire j'ai pris des actions remy
nice qui était très au courant de ce qui
se passe si ce que les courriels des
montres répondu aux questions cette
deuxième semaine de campagne électorale
a donc été marqué par le témoignage de
nigel wright l'ancien chef de cabinet de
stephen harper au procès d'ofi alors je
retrouve d'achat à toronto daniel à
ottawa michels et aux jets à montréal
bonsoir à vous trois alors d'abord un
témoignage très en taule très attendu en
tout cas pour les mordus de politique
comme vous notamment qu'est ce qu'on
apprend de 9 depuis deux jours
daniel on apprend qu'il ya eu au bureau
du premier ministre harper une vaste
opération de camouflage
je dirais même une vaste opération de
mensonges a sorti souvent de
contradictions de confusion
d'obstruction systématique à l'endroit
des comités du sénat de deloitte touche
de tous ces gens qui vous inquiéter
sérieusement sur la sphère de fait plein
de gens dans l'entourage immédiat de ces
vagues rappeur savait exactement ce qui
se passait et est impliqué dans cette
opération de camouflage
ils n'ont rien dit au premier ministre
harper et plus encore le 1er mai harper
n'a posé aucune question pendant tout ce
temps écoutez moi j'ai l'impression ce
soir que le premier ministre vient
d'entrer à la suite de ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui est de ceux dont nous
parlait manuel tout à l'heure le premier
c'est rentrer dans une zone de
turbulences très intense alors daniel
vous faites référence bien sûr on fait
que
l'un des plus proches conseillers de
stephen rapp donc les téléphones il a
été promu il est aujourd'hui maintenant
dans cette campagne électorale avec
semaine un peu et donc savait que le
courriel de dix ans je remet un chèque
de 90 milles de là rama yade au fait est
ce soir les conservateurs disent que
monsieur novak la place aux valeurs ce
courriel oui tasha vous qu'est-ce que
vous retournez retenez surtout de 7,2 ce
témoignage son premier conseiller à lui
peut être c'est dieu parce qu'il a
suivie la bible dans toute cette affaire
pour s'assurer qu'il a bien agi selon
lui par dieu oui à écoute je connais
majorettes
c'est bien c'est un homme honorable mais
ce que moi je retiens de ça que ce
n'était pas son honneur en verre magda
fille qui se souciait c'était envers le
premier ministre qu'il protégeait à tout
prix et moi je retrouve en a fait trop a
pris de nouveau dans le sens que
monsieur harper ni continuellement pas
impliqué directement dans la ferme à joe
wright n'a pas dit oui il était au
courant du chèque de 90 mais dollars il
a dit au contraire qui ne l'était pas
c'est on s'attendait à savoir la réponse
à cette question
alors même si les proches du premier
ministre était au courant de cette
affaire comme on sait maintenant
monsieur harper toujours on ne peut pas
prouver qu' il était lui lui même
impliqué directement ce qui est la seule
bonne chose dans ces nouvelles pour les
consommateurs mais autrement la semaine
a été plutôt difficile michel avait
l'air sceptique bâche un peu sceptique
place ou d'abord quand on évoque la
moralité vous savez quand tu fais le
monde large choix pour ta main droite je
pense que tout ce que fait ta main
gauche
d'abord je pense pas que la plupart des
canadiens considéré que le chèque de 90
mille dollars à mcdo fait et une au
monde n'entrent pas dans la définition
conventionnelle
alors ça c'est la première chose et si
on veut s'inspirer de la moralité
chrétienne comme ça la moralité c'est
aussi dire la vérité
or de toute évidence monsieur white n'a
pas dit la vérité aux canadiens sur l'
on espérait que les canadiens achètent
l'histoire que mac de fait avait
remboursé le trésor public à la et ça il
ya beaucoup de gens dans l'entourage du
premier ministre
il n'est pas clair on verra quand tous
les courriels ont été décortiquées
liliane de 800 des pets courriel qui ont
été déposées aujourd'hui si le premier
ministre n'a pas été mis au courant
quelque part mais à la fin il est clair
que au cabinet du premier ministre
on faisait une entreprise de couverture
des faits est une entreprise comme celle
là dans tous les scandales politiques
depuis 20 30 40 ans ça se fait aussi mal
que le problème lui-même quatre français
quand le pauvre à paris ça fait aussi
mal que les faibles ce qui rend tout ça
difficile c'est que tous ceux qui
connaissent bien ce qu'il verra le
savent qu'ils contrôlent tout tout tout
qui veut tout savoir ce qui se passe
autour de lui et c'était pour son
gouvernement et pour le parti
conservateur quelque chose d'explosif de
très dangereux qui n'est pas poser
toutes les questions
écoutez moi je viens faire un acte de
foi j'ai déjà été croyant je veux bien
faire un acte de foi je veux bien croire
en dieu comme nigel wright mais je peux
pas m'empêcher d'avoir des doutes parce
que quand même quand on parle d'une
opération de camouflage on se rend
compte avec tous ces courriels que ça
impliquait beaucoup de monde au bureau
du premier ministre dans sa garde
rapprochée et achats oui certainement un
rhino vague figure là dedans
steven chu au ch'ti qui est présentement
un des agents de communication dieu de
la campagne conservatrice était
apparemment la personne qui coordonnait
l'écriture des lignes médiatique à
l'époque alors ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont encore dans le décor des
conservateurs qui sont nommés dans ses
courriels là ce qui fait penser bon c
est ce qu est ce qu on peut croire ce
que la campagne dit présentement si on
était aussi intéressé aux à la
subterfuges ou au subterfuge
vingt-deux années mais quand on regarde
tous les efforts dont qui ont été mis
pour camoufler ce qu'avait fait enfin
pour protéger premier ministe protéger
le gouvernement camoufler c'était arrivé
on peut se demander pourquoi un moment
donné personne ne s'est dit mon mac do
fille il a fait ça ben il peut être
qu'il est temps de sacrifier de laisser
tomber non michel oui ça c'est une des
questions qui demeurent encore bien
posée monsieur de fait par contre être
très utile au premier ministre il
réchauffer les salles quand on a quand
on avait des assemblée partisane était
très aimé des pâtes des partisans
conservateurs
quel moment donné dans une histoire
comme ça ça prend une vie qui est pro
qui lui est propre et un moment donné on
perd des fois le sens des réalités c'est
pourquoi à un moment donné quelqu'un
fait un chèque de 90 mille dollars
monsieur dauphin mais le problème reste
entier
par exemple aujourd'hui on dit monsieur
novak a oui aussi été mis en copie sur
le courriel de wright 10 ha je vais lui
faire un chèque le dit mais il n'a pas
ouvert
écoutez ça c'est la version moderne de
le chien a mangé mon devoir là comme on
peut à un moment donné ces choses-là
creuseront pu est assez évident et vous
savez quand vous savez vous savez quand
même y semer des pieds dans les plats
quand un ministre devient embarrassant
pour le gouvernement
n'importe quel gouvernement au québec en
ontario en salle et on essaie de sauver
pendant quelques jours et ensuite on le
jette par la fenêtre pour ne pas
embarrasser davantage de gouvernements
c'est histoire dure deux semaines et à
un moment donné on passe à autre chose
ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
maintenu une histoire pendant près de
trois ans maintenant alors qu'il y avait
une solution toute simple c'est à dire
un mcdo fais ce que tu as fait ça n'a
aucune espèce valurent salut bonjour
veaux joyent un wes achats ce qui est
intéressant pour moi c'est que nos jours
a été dit effectivement qu'il ne croyait
pas que ce que monsieur duffy a fait
était contre la loi c'était contre l
éthique mais pas contre la loi et ça
c'est très important parce que on
comprend peut-être un peu mieux pourquoi
monsieur koffi a dit écoute je ne veux
pas jouer le juge par payer ces sommes
là je n'ai pas à les repayer
et là ce serait tout là toute la
question du délai l'éthique du sénat et
des règlements et du fait que monsieur
harper avait mis messieurs d'affilée
dans le sénat alors c'était pas mon
protégé mac d'office et de vous protéger
le premier ministre est en jeu
l'image du parti que tout le monde sait
tourner en rond et je pense pas qu'au
début de cette affaire il pensait que ça
allait de trouver telle ampleur qu'elle
a trouvé depuis
pas du tout bon alors évidemment on est
en campagne électorale
la campagne de monsieur rappeur et
beaucoup basé son son leadership est ce
que ça peut imposer alors michel quel
impact tout ça peut avoir sur stephen
rapp ort est ce que ça va jouer je veux
que vous disiez au début de l'entretien
céline qu'on était des passionnés de
politique et que les gens suivent
peut-être pas ça autant que nous mais ce
que ça comme un fait ça c'est très clair
c'est que les gens entendent parler
maintenant depuis deux jours que au
bureau du premier ministre du canada y
avait de la magouille et ça ça nuit à
monsieur un peu c'est évident ça peut
démobiliser ses propres partisans
ça peut bien sûr mobiliser les autres et
il faut pas oublier depuis le début de
la campagne me suis un peu fait
littéralement une campagne qui s'adresse
à sa base à ses partisans et en se
disant de toute évidence si j'ai ma base
je vais gagner celui d'un point très
grosse marge de manoeuvre si démobilise
sa base il peut avoir des gros gros
problème c'est cette balle c'est quoi
ces 6 30 % de canadiens qui ne voteront
jamais pour un autre parti que le parti
conservateur ou qui resteront chez eux
c'est des purs et durs conservateur mais
pour gagner s'ils veulent n'a pas eu
besoin de 34 35 % trois gouvernements en
minorité à 37,38 comme la dernière fois
pour une majorité et ses 6 5 à 8% qui
vont te dire à partir de maintenant bon
ben il était vraiment le temps de passer
à autre chose et tout ce que j'ai
entendu ce gouvernement qui devrait être
plus blanc que blanc plus pur que pure
et peu mieux que les autres finalement
juste rester à la maison à sa
belle-fille there c'est oui c'est vrai
sauf que sauf que on est en début de
campagne et je pense que c'était une
décision stratégique de conservateur
d'ouvrir la campagne aussitôt pour
essentiellement laisser faire du reste à
faire pendant quelques jours et ensuite
passer à autre chose après que monsieur
wright n'est plus le témoin le procès de
voir ne va pas être aussi intéressant
les autres questions de la campagne les
autres annonces les autres débats tout
ça va survenir et je pense que les
conservateurs espèrent qu'à la fin de la
journée oui ça à rappeler aux canadiens
les problèmes éthiques du gouvernement
mais qu'ils vont vont analyser ça et
dire que ce n'était pas la chose qui
vont les pousser à lui on ne va pas être
la question dominante à l'élection même
dans ce que vous dites c'est qu'ils ont
que les conservateurs ont déclenché
l'élection toute connaissance de cause
ça chambre ça leur nuire est patente ça
absolument parce qu'ils savent qu'en
même temps qu' il y à ce procès on a des
annonces du parti libéral on a des
questions d'autres d'annonce du parti
npd
il ya d'autres choses qui se passent en
même temps alors les médias sont divisés
la tension ne portent pas tous sur le
procès comme il l'aurait fait s'il n'y
avait pas une campagne qui se passait en
même temps mais c'est toi qui déjoue
sert avec plusieurs jeux 18 jours de
chaos c'est très long michel mais c'est
un gros pari de faire sa dérive on
l'oublié avec le temps parce que quand
on s'attaque aux questions éthiques ça
dure longtemps vous lui demanderez à
paul martin qui a pas été mise en cause
personnellement dans ce scandale des
commandites mais l'ensemble du parti
libéral n'étaye à payer les pots cassés
de soirée c'était des millions de
dollars de l'argent des contribuables
ici c'est 90 mille dollars de la poste
et nigel wright c'est pas la même chose
même si la racine de la chose est la
même c'est pas le même montant d'argent
mais une question d'éthique quand même
gagne elle et moi je
est-ce que quand les gens vont aller
voter le 19 octobre 11 0 michael jaffe
je ne vote pas pour mike daf et
j'entendais hier un analyse d'hier
pendant la dernière semaine de campagne
électorale compter sur les libéraux et
surtout le nouveau parti démocratique
pour vous montrer la vie net de madoff
et des autres sénateurs qui ont eu des
problèmes pendant toute la semaine juste
avant le vote
ça va suivre sur un peu à mon avis
jusqu'à la fin de la campagne ce sera
peut-être pas le sujet principal des
prochains débats télévisés on va
sûrement revenir sur des questions
d'éthique mais sa voix de suivre et
l'embarrasser je suis à la fin de la
campagne je suis certain qu'ils
aimeraient bien mieux par voir ce boulet
là au pied pendant ce temps les autres
chefs de parti s'en sorte qu'on commande
en cette deuxième semaine
un petit mot michel écoutez monsieur
trudeau surprend quand même encore un
petit peu de et depuis la campagne est
commencée et performe très bien je pense
pas qu'on ait encore vu le vrai thomas
mulcair
on lui dit trop de sourires et de poids
et de quoi être lui-même ça commence à
paraître
on disait washington d'être eisenberger
bolquère qu'il soit lui même ça va il va
probablement être plus efficace au
québec ce qui est en train d'arriver
c'est vraiment une chose à une descente
aux enfers du bloc québécois gilles
duceppe appuie d'instituer perdu l'appui
la ftq aujourd'hui monsieur péladeau ben
monsieur péladeau en fin de conférence
de presse à un dab la main monsieur
mulcair sur les pipelines banc puis
ensuite en disant bien il ya trop de
nuances à faire sur les hydrocarbures je
peux pas vous répondre en 30 secondes
salades et pommes jeudi soutenues bondi
second d'achat ce qui m'a surpris le
plus c'est la sottise que justin trudeau
a dit cette semaine sur l'économie du
coeur d'une économie du coeur ça veut
dire quoi c'est un non sens du tout qui
retrouve non seulement le langage mais
le sens économique parce que c'est
l'enjeu principal de la campagne à la
fin de la journée alors le
contre-interrogatoire se poursuit de
monsieur nigel wright on aura l'occasion
de s'en reparler on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup à vous
trois au revoir